Harry Styles' beauty brand, Pleasing,
just got a new poster boy.
The Los Angeles times report rock legend,
Mick Fleetwood, is the face of Shroom Bloom,
Harry's latest collection of face and nail products.
Look at this.
Mick is one of Harry's musical heroes.
He grew up on Fleetwood Mac, hello, we all did.
And describes Mick as a magical man of wizardry.
We cannot agree more.
Look at this, right?
All these images,
Harry Styles just for me, does everything right.
From his albums to his aesthetic to these products
and the way he markets it, his vision,
I just think it's so one of a kind
I also think it's really on trend.
I think my prediction for the world,
everything is going to become mushroom.
Really?
Yes, absolutely.
I know that sounds silly, but it's not.
Mycelium is going to be the next great resource.
It grows underneath the ground,
it's what the mushrooms grow out of.
But it's like trees in that absorbs all of our toxins,
and you know, people are making clothes out of it.
It's gonna be the biggest thing in fashion.
It's gonna be like the next great resource.
But I just think shrooms will be trending real heavily.
Mushroom, I'm investing in mushrooms.
Invest in that mushroom.
Wow.
Well turning to a food
that doesn't feel, I mean, as divisive.
Okay, it's the food of the future, apparently,
they're creepy, they're crawly,
and they're today's food news.
(audience cheering)
We are not feeling great about...
So the Albuquerque Journal reports
that there's one protein everyone's talking about,
and that would be bugs.
Insects have been in diets around the world for ages,
but now there's a new interest in insects
as a sustainable food choice.
Urgh.
Insects take less water and land to cultivate
than other animal proteins.
And today, we have been challenged
with seeing what all the buzz is about with a bug flight.
I don't...
(audience cheering)
We have a special guest taster, Beth Nidic, are you here?
I'm right here.
You're gonna taste these?
Yes.
I have teenage boys and they always eat like gross stuff.
So when this came up, I was like, I gotta do it,
they do it, mom's gotta do it.
You know who loves eating bugs?
It's a joke.
No, who?
My ant, no.
That's stupid.
Oh my God, well, ironically, we don't have ants.
We have a tarantula.
Oh my gosh.
Look what I have here, Drew, a scorpion, look.
Urgh.
Crickets, silkworms, a sago worm, don't know what that is,
and grasshoppers.
I don't know if I can do it.
Okay.
All right, Beth, are you gonna do one of these?
I'm using barbecue sauce.
Okay, you're using barbecue sauce
and you're going with the silkworm?
Yes.
Oh God Drew, are you gonna do this?
Think potato chip.
Think potato chip, okay.
Oh God, oh God, oh.
Sharing.
Oh God.
I'm gonna lose my nerve.
Okay, oh God.
I can't, the tarantula is really freaking me out.
I feel like you should have sauce.
Nick.
Nick, Nick, Nick, Nick.
(audience cheering)
Think of a potato chip.
What are you gonna do?
Let's see.
I don't even wanna touch it.
I'm gonna...
Oh, she's doing it, she's doing it, she's doing it.
(audience cheering)
I'm not kidding, it is totally delicious.
Oh, so what does it taste like?
Describe it.
Like a crunchy treat.
Really?
Ross, why don't you try it,
and you can tell me what it tastes like.
Oh, there is an after taste.
Oh God, okay, I'm gonna do one.
Are you gonna do one?
I ate that one, there is an aftertaste.
Ross, Ross, Ross, Ross, Ross, Ross, Ross.
(audience cheering)
Did you see me, I was so brave, I was.
Did you do the scorpion?
Did anyone do the scorpion?
Will anyone do the scorpion?
You raised your hand.
(audience cheering)
Oh my God, yuck.
I'm so excited.
Oh my God, oh my God.
(audience cheering)
That is incredible.
This was so much fun.
Yeah, well, I have to say this sort of bugged me.
(upbeat music)